People can't get enough of the Clown Prince
of Crime.
At least, that's what Warner Brothers seems
to think, now that news has emerged that not
one, but two solo movies for the character
are being developed.
It's a move that raises a lot of questions
for the casual moviegoer.
Is Jared Leto still the Joker, or are we getting
Joaquin Phoenix?
And if they're both the Joker, how?
We've got the answers to all of this and more,
so if you're wondering why everything seems
to be coming up Joker, stay with us.
Developing DC
Warner Brothers' DC Extended Universe is a
movie series that's hard to talk about without
bringing up comparisons to Marvel.
Launched in 2013 with Man of Steel, the DCEU
is a direct response to the success that Marvel
Studios and Disney have been having with their
cinematic universe since the release of Iron
Man in 2008.
Big differences have emerged in the way we
learn about upcoming movies in each franchise.
Regarding Marvel, we generally don't know
what they're working on until they officially
announce something, meaning that by the time
we hear about a movie that they're doing,
we can be fairly confident it's actually going
to happen.
DC takes the opposite approach, with leaks
and rumors emerging about a downright confusing
number of movies in development, some of which
will more than likely never see the light
of day.
It's almost too much to keep track of, making
things extra confusing for the casual fan.
"Cuz there's been talk of like, the Harley-Joker
film, and the Gotham City Sirens.
Are those two distinct things, are you talking
about the Sirens project?"
"No, it's a totally separate one."
"Oh my god."
The joke book
Let's talk about the DC movies just related
to the Joker, in order of how likely they
seem to actually happen.
First off, there's Suicide Squad 2, which
is reportedly set to feature Jared Leto returning
to the role as part of an ensemble.
Next, there's the most-recently announced
Joker solo movie, also set to center on Leto's
Joker.
Then there's the biggest wild card of all:
the Martin Scorsese-produced, Todd Phillips-directed,
Joaquin Phoenix-led Joker origin movie.
Finally, there's the "twisted romantic comedy"
project featuring Harley Quinn and the Joker.
Supposedly, this movie replaces the Gotham
City Sirens movie we've heard so many reports
about, which also was reportedly going to
involve Leto's Joker.
In other words, Warner Brothers could currently
be working on no less than four different
films involving the Joker, two of them solo
movies with completely different actors.
The obvious question is how the Joaquin Phoenix
movie could possibly fit in with the tone
established by Leto's Joker, much less the
continuity of the DCEU.
The answer is simple: It won't.
Elseworlds
Even before Justice League saw a theatrical
release, word was out that Warner Brothers
was in the process of re-evaluating its strategy
regarding DC Comics movies.
Specifically, the studio started exploring
the possibility that this whole shared universe
thing might not be all it's cracked up to
be.
They'd hardly be the only ones to screw up
a movie mega-verse.
[Yelling and crashing]
Word is, Warner Brothers is in the process
of creating a new banner for movies to take
place outside of shared universe continuity.
Under this arrangement, multiple actors will
be able to play the same role, with anything
that happens outside the shared universe being
irrelevant to it.
That way, any actor will be able to play the
Joker on the big screen in an alternate-universe
story, having no effect on the storyline of
Jared Leto's Joker.
It works for DC's animated universe, so why
not the big screen?
For now, this separate banner remains untitled,
and Warner Brothers hasn't done a whole lot
to make the general public aware that they're
making this move, leaving the door open for
what feels like an unnecessary amount of confusion.
Jokin' Phoenix
So, what is this alternate-universe, Elseworlds-style
Joker movie?
Here's what we know right now.
According to reports, DC is developing a solo
Joker origin story starring Joaquin Phoenix,
directed by Todd Phillips of The Hangover
series fame.
Phillips is co-writing the script with Scott
Silver, who wrote 8 Mile and The Fighter.
The movie is being produced in part by Martin
Scorsese, and at this point, there's every
indication that Phoenix really has signed
on for the role, though he's publicly been
cagey about his involvement so far.
A lot of the information that we have about
this movie's premise comes from MMA fighter-turned-comedian
Brendan Schaub, who spilled some showbiz gossip
during an appearance on the Joe Rogan Experience
podcast.
"As a kid, he had like a permanent smile and
everyone made fun of him.
It's like on the streets of Brooklyn.
It's like super dark and real.
I can't wait."
Joker: A Joker Story
Right now, not much is known about Jared Leto's
Joker movie.
The hunt is currently on for a director and
a screenwriter, and it's unknown whether the
movie will be produced before or after Suicide
Squad 2.
Either way, the earliest we'll see this is
in 2019.
As for the plot?
Well, it probably won't be an origin story.
Leto going forward with the movie would seem
to indicate that any bad blood that may have
existed between him and Warner Brothers has
more or less dissolved.
If you'll recall, Leto seemed pretty peeved
at the way his Suicide Squad work was treated
in the editing room, with most of his involved
performance ending up on the cutting room
floor.
Elseworlds apart
If the Elseworlds-style banner takes off,
there are many stories in DC's stable that
might get adaptations.
One potential project Warner Brothers was
once considering is Superman: Red Son, a story
that imagines how things might have shaken
out had the Kryptonian crash-landed in the
USSR.
As a story, it's the perfect example of what
this alternate world movie banner could accomplish.
Making multiple Joker films may sound like
the strangest way to start it, but if Warner
Brothers hits on something, it could very
well revolutionize the way studios approach
comic book movies.
Maybe it's time to go to the next level, and
wouldn't it be funny if DC was the one who
leads us there?
Despite the mistakes of even the rather recent
past, it could work out for everyone.
And that's no joke.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!